The great scientist J-Kwon once hypothesized
“errybody in the club getting tipsy” but
he failed to mention the effect it had on
their sperm.
Welcome to DNews, I’m Ross Everett and alcohol
might be messing with your swimmers.
A study conducted on 1,200 Danish men, stop
me if you’ve heard this one, showed that
drinking as much as one alcoholic beverage
a week can lower the quality of your boys.
I’m talking about sperm, which might indeed
one day yield you actual boys if used properly.
Not just quantity, sperm killing is for the
birds, the study found that a lifestyle lending
itself to one simple drink a week could affect
sperm concentration, count, and percentage
of healthy and normal sperm.
Essentially taking your Michael Phelps’
and leaving you with Michael Welps.
The study was conducted during the men’s
physical examination before joining the army,
as was mandatory in Denmark between 2008 and
2012.
They asked the men how much alcohol they drank
the week before the assessment and whether
or not that was the typical amount they drank
to rule out binge drinking or special occasions.
And while alcohol consumption led to testosterone
levels rising, it caused the sex hormone binding
globulin to fall, which makes sense because
the glycoprotein is produced mostly by the
liver, which is also the part of the body
people apologize to on Facebook after a night
of heavy drinking.
Of course, the heavier drinkers who consumed
more than five drinks a week saw the greatest
change in their little Olympians lowering
their sperm count by 33% and their normal-looking
sperm by 51%, but even those who only slurped
down one drink a week showed a slight decrease.
Keep in mind this was just an observational
study so other possible factors, including
lifestyle choices of those who tend to drink
more, weren’t taken into account, but similar
animal studies suggest that alcohol does have
a direct impact on sperm quality.
What do you guys think, is this a public health
concern or could this just be a nice way to
control the population with a buzz?
Let me know in the comments down below.
And speaking of drinking if you’re wondering
why the RedBull part of those Vodka RedBulls
hasn’t been actually give you wings, you
can check out this video about a guy who is
suing them for false advertisement and winning.
Thanks for watching DNews - don’t forget
to subscribe!